[Music]
the physical books just worked for me
they work really well for note-taking
they work really well for annotation
they give you something tangible and
there's something about it that I can't
quite explain
right like you can know something's in a
book on the left-hand side of the page
between page eighty and ninety but if
you're reading on a Kindle you can't do
that so reading on the Kindle is great
and I use a Kindle for traveling but the
vast majority of the reading I do I try
to do in physical books because I can
write about the idea in my own
penmanship I can draw arrows and
pictures and diagrams and try to connect
the argument that the author is trying
to make because how can I agree or
disagree with somebody if I don't
understand the fundamental principles of
the argument that somebody is trying to
make one of the ways you can deconstruct
that is just sort of being actively
attuned to what you're reading I find
when I read on the Kindle I'm not
necessarily as actively engaged in the
book but if I'm taking notes and I'm
following along with the article or I'm
occasionally underlining a word that I
don't even know what it means and I want
to go look it up later but it means that
I'm actively reading that what I'm
paying attention to which is super
important and also one of the other
things that I find easier to do with a
physical book although you can do it
with a Kindle book I call it sort of
like the blank sheet what we do there is
we just sort of before you read a book
you take a blank sheet of paper and you
write down what you know about that
subject you can mindmap it you can write
it and sort of like bullet points and
then you read maybe a paragraph or not a
paragraph you read a chapter of that
book and that's all the reading time you
have for that day well now you go to
that sheet and use a different color pen
and you just fill in like what gaps that
I learned did I learn a different
terminology for the words can i connect
it to what I've already read and then
before you pick up the book for the next
chapter you read that you just skim this
sheet and it sort of primes your brain
for what you're going to read and I
think that that's a really effective way
to sort of like not only build on the
knowledge you have but connect what
you're reading to the to the existing
knowledge it's going to show you what
you learned while you were reading
because it's going to be a very visual
distinction it's going to be a different
color of ink and I think that that
allows you to sort of like connect
to the book and aft and do that in the
jacket of the book where if I don't have
a physical piece of paper that's okay
because I can just do it on on the front
cover that is so much harder when you
try to translate that to electronic it's
possible but it's a lot more difficult
[Music]